Radio:
«… Tout cela promet une belle journée pour les scorpions.
Culture à présent, le ministre de la culture
Stéphane Born propose de faire classer au
patrimoine de l'Unesco TOUS les châteaux
ayant appartenu à des rois de France, et
déclare à ce propos «suivez-moi».»
Lucretia:
La gueuse?
Aliénor:
C'est «Aliénor», pour toi! Kestuveux?
Lucretia:
Je voulais savoir si c'était la Prof qui
venait de claquer la porte si élégamment.
Aliénor:
A ton avis, ça peut être qui d'autre?
J'ai pas le droit de sortir
parce que gnagnagna j'fais peur aux gens...
Évidemment, tu es le sosie de la Prof.
Alors si les voisins te voient sortir en costume
XVe siècle et sursauter à la moindre voiture,
il est normal qu'ils se posent des questions.
Aliénor:
J'connais les voitures.
J'étais juste pas prête pour les tracteurs.
Et puis tu lui ressembles pas aussi, peut-être?
Lucretia:
J'ai de bien meilleurs cheveux.
Enfin, bref.
Si nous pouvions laisser cette histoire
de côté...
Il faut qu'on parle.
Aliénor:
Alors, tu veux quoi? Si c'est encore pour
me parler de l'hygiène, je te rappelle que
les gens de mon époque sont très propres
et c'est à la Renaissance que...
Lucretia:
Je veux enterrer le pilum de guerre.
Est-ce que tu te souviens comment tu es arrivée
ici? Ton attitude désinvolte et frivole
me fait penser que non, mais
sait-on jamais...
Aliénor:
T'es vachement douée pour faire la paix,
tu le sais? Non, j'm'en souviens pas.
Je suis juste apparue ici, comme toi, et crois
moi j'étais mieux quand t'étais pas là.
Lucretia:
Tu dois forcément avoir quelque chose en
tête, un dernier souvenir...
Raconte-moi ce que tu faisais, avant d'arriver.
A moins que ça aussi t'aie échappé.
Aliénor:
Ça, je sais.
J'étais à la cueillette aux champignons...
Godefroy:
Mademoiselle Aliénor!
Aliénor:
Sire Godefroy...
Que faites-vous ici?
Godefroy:
J'entraîne les faucons du duc.
Aliénor:
Mais...
Je ne vois pas de faucons.
Godefroy:
Ils volent.
C'est le but de l'exercice.
Mais vous, que me vaut votre présence en
ces bois?
Aliénor:
Je cherche des champignons.
Godefroy:
C'est déjà la saison?
Soit, je ne vous dérangerai pas plus longtemps.
Soyez prudente et fermez bien votre cape,
la forêt n'est pas toujours sûre.
Oui, merci.
Aliénor:
Ça doit pas être la saison.
Y'a quelqu'un? Sire Godefroy?
Aliénor:
Et après ça, le trou noir, je me suis retrouvée
dans la chambre de la prof.
Et toujours pas de champignons.
Lucretia:
Étrange...
Aliénor:
Bah oui, j'étais sûre que c'était la saison.
Lucretia:
Pas ça, idiote.
Je veux dire qu'il est étrange que tu ne
te souvienne plus des conditions qui t'ont
amenée ici, alors que j'en ai un souvenir
très exact.
Probablement un défaut lié à ton manque
de...
Aliénor:
Attends, tu sais pourquoi on est ici?
Lucretia:
Ici précisément, non, mais...
La Prof:
C'est moi!
Lucretia:
Une autre fois.
C'est promis.
La Prof:
Vous vous êtes toujours pas entre-dévorées?